today on the matt walsh show a teacher
in washington read a trans
indoctrination book to her first grade
students the school board didn't take
any action against her probably because
the board is run by a woman who owns an
all-ages sex toy shop
this is the state of the modern school
system we'll talk about it also we'll
discuss the birthing person controversy
just in time for birthing person day and
in our five headlines caitlyn jenner
continues to be a train wreck the jobs
report proves that it's probably not a
good idea to pay people to not work who
would have thought and uh alexandria
casa cortez credits planned parenthood
with saving babies finally in our daily
cancellation uh we'll talk about the
case of a high school girl who faces
over a decade in prison for trying to
rig her homecoming election
maybe a little bit overkill we might
think a lot to get to today and we'll
get to all that today on the matt wells
show
[Music]
now checking in with bambi you know uh
if you're a business owner you have
probably enough things to deal with as a
business owner challenges obstacles you
have to get over every single day uh and
why why should hr why should all the
things that come with hr be one of the
problems you have to deal with on a
daily basis when running a business hr
issues can kill you wrongful termination
suits minimum wage requirements labor
regulations all of it also on top of
that hr manager salaries aren't cheap
average of 70 000 a year we're talking
bam b spelled b a m b e e was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated hr manager craft hr
policy and maintain your compliance all
for just 99 a month uh with bambi you
can change hr from your biggest
liability to one of your biggest
strengths your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat
and they handle everything from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
they help you manage your employees day
to day all for just
99 a month it's that easy it's that
affordable so go to bambi.com walsh
right now and uh schedule your free hr
audit that's bambi.com well spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh
this story begins with the standard
level of public school degeneracy but
then gets darkened darker and darker as
you plunge down the rabbit hole our
friends over at yaf have the report out
of bellingham school district in
washington according to an anonymous tip
they received a first grade teacher by
the name of jennifer miller
read a trans propaganda book called i am
jazz to the six and seven-year-old
children in her first grade class
this was done apparently without asking
the parents permission or notifying them
ahead of time of course
now subscribers to my youtube channel
and if you're not a subscriber you
should become one uh maybe familiar with
the book i am jazz because we did a
video a few months ago where i read that
book and this story out of bellingham
school district
is exactly why i read it kids are being
subjected to this kind of thing in
school and it's important that you
understand what exactly we're dealing
with more specifically what your kids
are dealing with
to summarize i am jazz tells the true
life tale of jazz jennings a boy who
began
transitioning into a girl from the age
of like four or five because his mom is
a munchausen abuser who projected her
own mania onto her helpless little boy
now that's my own editorial that's not
what the book says exactly what the book
does say is that jazz was a boy with a
girl stuck inside him or rather he was a
boy with a girl's brain stuck inside him
somehow now how does a boy end up with a
girl brain what does it actually mean
isn't a brain inside a boy's head
automatically a boy a boy brain
literally by definition
i mean is it like the definition of a
boy brain uh like
the the brain inside of a boy is a boy
brain isn't that what that is
well the book doesn't get into these
questions at all
here's how the book presents it i'll
play a clip here of jazz jennings
himself actually reading
the book here it is let's watch
i have a girl brain but a boy body this
is called transgender i was born this
way
when i was very little and my mom would
say you're such a good boy i would say
no mama good girl
at first my family was confused they'd
always thought of me as a boy
as i got a little older i hardly ever
played with trucks or tools or
superheroes only princesses and mermaid
costumes my brothers told me this was
girl stuff i kept right on playing
my sister says i was always talking to
her about my girl thoughts and my girl
dreams and how one day i would be a
beautiful lady
she would giggle and say you're a funny
kid
sometimes my parents let me wear my
sister's dresses around the house but
whenever we went out i had to put on my
boy clothes again this made me mad
still i never gave up trying to convince
them
pretending i was a boy felt like telling
a lie
your parents were confused
his parents were confused
i'm confused
uh his parents were confused when the
boy says uh no mommy i'm a girl
and the parents said what i'm so
confused what's going on what's what's
happening oh it's just your kid being a
kid that's what's happening your kid
just your kid is simply babbling like
kids do
not much to be confused about
but this is what children are being
taught in school it's the brainwashing
that um first graders in the bellingham
school district had to endure
which is what caused some parents to
email the teacher understandably
outraged and demand answers now as yaf
reports the teacher jennifer miller
responded to one email saying
yes i did read this book as a district
we are working hard to support all
members of our school community and
promote inclusion through understanding
and compassion
yes understanding she is promoting
understanding
by making wild anti-scientific claims
about girl brains getting accidentally
planted inside the skulls of little boys
maybe there's some kind of mix-up on the
assembly line in heaven i don't know
and she's promoting compassion by
normalizing the psychological and sexual
abuse of children
right makes total sense
but as i warn this story gets even more
deranged
parents took their plight to the school
board hoping to find a sane person
somewhere who would hold this pervert
teacher accountable but sadly this
school board did nothing and that's
probably because the president of the
school board is another jennifer
jennifer mason
who lists her first of all lists her
pronouns in her instagram bio so it kind
of tells you where she's coming from but
far worse than that
she also runs a self-described all-ages
sex toy shop no i didn't miss speak it
is an all ages sex toy shop and all ages
really means all ages
reading now from the yaf report
it says an investigation by yaff
revealed that jennifer mason president
of the bellingham school school board
owns and operates a self-described
all-ages sex toy shop
according to a local paper
mason said while the store only sells
for those ages 16 and older
16 and older at the sex toy shop
people of any age can be in the store
i want to be i want to show people if
i want to show people if sex isn't
something to be ashamed about um i
should be able to be an elected official
and own a sex toy shop at the same time
mason told the local paper that's what
it means to live your values
well that part is true i mean she is
living her values she is living by the
values of a demented freak
and she's running the school board by
those same values
these are also the values of the most
powerful people and institutions in
america
which perhaps lends some context to a
moment yesterday that got plenty of
attention and provoked plenty of
laughter when representative corey bush
um one of the newest members of the
squad i believed addressed a house
committee and used a certain phrase
let's listen to that clip
i sit before you today
as a single mom as a nurse as an
activist and as a congresswoman and i am
committed to doing the absolute most to
protect black mothers to protect black
babies to
protect black birthing people and to
save lives thank you and i yield back
birthing people
of course many jokes
can be made about this and have been
made about this and should be made about
this and yeah that's all good it
deserves to be mocked
relentlessly and ruthlessly
so we can of course joke about how we're
gonna call our moms on sunday to wish a
happy birthing person day or
we could start talking about how we need
to rewrite some song titles like when a
man loves a birthing person and man i
feel like a birthing person and then you
know american birthing person and
witching burst birthing person
um you get the idea all the jokes are
great but underneath the well-deserved
mockery
is
a pretty insidious truth
that they're trying to rewrite reality
they're taking all that is good and true
and beautiful and they're emptying it
out
and twisting it into hideous
unrecognizable shapes
and making everything ugly and weird and
meaningless
what we need desperately to understand
and what cannot possibly be emphasized
enough is that these people
when i say these people i mean the ones
running schools and school boards and
classrooms and state houses all the way
up to congress and the white house
they have a deep seething hatred for all
that they consider to be old and
traditional and outmoded
we could say that they don't trust any
truth that they didn't invent themselves
five seconds ago
they want to break down not only human
civilization but humanity itself and
build it all up again in their own
deranged image
they believe they have a moral license
to do whatever needs to be done in order
to bring bring that about
certainly brainwashing your child is one
of those things
that's why that teacher when she was
called on it
she didn't
apologize or anything like that she said
yeah i read the book what are you going
to do about it
i'll read whatever i want to your kid
because these are my values
and they're the correct values
they don't recognize your moral or
natural authority as a parent over your
own children
because you're one of the bad guys in
their minds
and they are saving your children from
you
by indoctrinating them into the the cult
of the chosen ones the enlightened ones
this is what we're up against
it's the hill that we're fighting on
and it really is the last hill
because it's the hill of reality itself
that's what the battle is over
and we really really cannot afford to
lose it
now let's get to our five headlines
you know if i am known for anything
which i'm probably not known for
anything at all but if i am it's my
beard you might say that's kind of sad
you know in media should not be known
for something other than the hair on my
face but but i'll take it
and i get so i get questions all the
time about how do i have such a glorious
beautiful beard and i always tell people
you know a lot some of it is just
natural but a lot of it is upkeep and
that's why you need a company like beard
supply and all the products that they
offer uh manly men grow beards here's
what they do they grow beards they grill
meat and they drink handcrafted boots
that's my opinion you can enter to win a
stash of goods from beard supply meat
church desert door howler brothers and
more badass brands for the red-blooded
american male one lucky winner will get
a collection of beard oils and grooming
essentials which really are essential to
having the beard of your dreams plus you
get tools for grilling and leather care
and a 200 gift card for an outdoor
menswear shopping spree you can up your
man game with this stash of goods you
don't want to miss out on this chance
but don't delay the beard supply spring
giveaway is ending soon so get on over
to beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter that's beardsupply.com
giveaway and good luck
all right so the new york post um has
the report on the jobs on the jobs
report
says some economists are emphasizing
patience during america's cover recovery
as the country maneuvers through what
could be a bumpy path to economic growth
the u.s added just 266 000 jobs in april
far below economists
expectations of 1 million
and the unemployment rate rose slightly
to 6.1 percent
the lower than expected data comes on
the heels of strong gains in march
which saw 770 000 jobs added about 150
000 lower than initially estimated uh so
right now we're trending
in the wrong direction and you can add
uh on top of the the
the jobs report not hitting anywhere
close to what they were expecting you
know again they were what was it they
were expecting 1.1
or were they expecting 1 million and got
266 000
but also we've got skyrocketing
inflation
and the prices of of gasoline and and
groceries going up everywhere
and and for some reason that's not being
and i say for some reason kind of
facetiously but that's not being
discussed very much
so i just wonder you know and i'm no
economist myself i'm no economic expert
i don't claim to be but
you know could it be
throwing this out there
that's all something for the for the
class to discuss
could it be that
as we have been doing
paying people
not to work
is a bad idea
could there be a correlation when you
pay people not to work
um and and we've been doing that of
course for decades but it's been ramped
up over the last year
you pay people out to work and then you
have fewer people working
could there be a connection pay people
not to work fewer people work hmm
can't quite figure it out i don't know
seems like they're you might be able to
connect those dots uh who knows
and then also
you start handing out billions of
dollars worth of checks
to millions of americans for no
discernible reason
and then prices go up
hmm once again um
i don't know it's almost like there's a
direct causal relationship between it's
almost like
any any person with an iq above 75 could
have seen this coming from a mile away
and i know when i say that we gave out
the checks for no discernible reason
that's going to upset some people and uh
and uh and i'll be told oh what do you
mean no reason didn't you hear about the
pandemic
no it was for no reason because we gave
out we didn't give out checks
only to people who had lost their jobs
uh we didn't give out checks
you know only to
um
people who had
lost money or lost their businesses
during the lockdowns that's not what we
did
we set
and when i say we actually the
government set an arbitrary line
according to uh to household income
and then just sent a check
multiple checks to everyone below that
line
regardless of whether they needed it or
not
and most of them didn't
the vast majority of people who got a
check didn't lose their job hadn't lost
any significant amount of money
were doing fine financially
the vast majority of people that got the
checks were in a
basically the same position financially
during the pandemic that they were in
before
and we said the checks anyway
billions and billions of dollars
printing that cash
um
to give out free money
and then prices go up
catastrophically suicidally stupid idea
and this is what happens as a result
and we haven't even seen the half of it
yet about what's going
what's coming
all right
moving on number two caitlyn jenner
you know
speaking of of
dying on the hill of defending reality
a lot of conservatives are not
interested in doing that
that's not a hill yeah a lot of
conservatives are saying right now
reality
who needs it we'll let we'll let the
left have
reality there's still some other hills
we can fight over
as long as we get those tax cuts that's
what matters
and those conservatives are lining up
behind
the caitlyn jenner candidacy and heaping
praise on caitlyn jenner making sure to
use the preferred pronouns
but jenna was interviewed um
by sean hannity a few days ago and
i i just want to play one clip for you
from this interview
uh and this this this is a clip that got
a lot of negative attention from the
left and i think actually in this case
for good reason let's listen
eighteen thousand companies have left
california my friends are leaving
california actually work my hair the guy
across front of redmond he was packing
up his hangers where are you going and
he says i'm moving to sedona arizona i
can't take it anymore i can't walk down
the streets and see the homeless
i don't want to leave
okay
either i stay and fight or i get out of
here
so his uh
he's telling us a story about his friend
at the private jet hangar
who was leaving california because he
doesn't want to see the homeless when he
walks down the street
he managed to take
the issue of people leaving california
for good reason and make it seem elitist
and unsympathetic
you know you think we have all the
sympathy in the world that's that's a
very easy it should be a very easy case
to make
people are leaving california got very
good reason to leave
we should be very sympathetic to the
people that are leaving
but he managed to botch that message
trying to explain why people are leaving
california and his pitch is well you
know the rich people with private jets
they don't want to see the homeless
that's literally what his case was that
he presented
caitlyn jenner a
terrible advocate
terrible communicator
not ineffective
representative of conservative values
largely because he doesn't have those
values at all
he supports tax cuts
and oh well he did say
only legal immigration
he loves immigration but only the legal
kind
and then when he was asked about what
about the people who were already here
who came here illegally well he said we
have to have compassion for them have
compassion and you know we know what
that means
in gop establishment parliaments what
that means is uh is we we should just
that means amnesty is what that means we
all know that
so caitlyn jenner uh trans rights ad
advocate
transgender himself
uh terrible advocate
for for conservative causes
really bad communicator
um no discernible qualifications or
leadership qualities at all
and we're gonna line up behind this why
oh well again because we we know it'll
give us the opportunity to make the case
that the dems are the real transphobes
that's what this is all about
oh and also um
speaking of caitlyn jenner's uh resume
and history
uh he remember back when he was awarded
a woman of the
year still hasn't given back that award
by the way
but he was awarded one woman of the year
and when he was doing that media tour i
think it was in the vogue what was a
vogue magazine where he was you know he
woman of the year did that whole spread
uh i think it was in that interview
where he said that he
tried to convince his
wife at the time
to abort his oldest daughter
so
uh that we can add that to his
conservative credentials
not only pro-abortion apparently but
actually was wanted to kill his own
child
great great candidate you got there
republicans great candidate
all right number three we haven't had a
mask shaming video in quite a while not
because they haven't been out there but
we haven't played one on the show
so i want to play this for you this was
a a woman
at a grocery store minding your own
business
when
a man came up and started
harassing her for not wearing a mask
let's watch
right there no mask
right there
there we go candy camera there we go i
want you to know that your insensitivity
is ridiculous i no longer have
grandparents due to this virus because
of people like you who don't want to
wear a mask in the store it's ridiculous
actually it's insensitive and it's
disgusting as a human being for you to
show so much privilege to all of these
people there are so many older people in
here who have health conditions other
people and i'm not gonna just i'm not oh
great oh whoopsie dude congratulations
for your pregnancy it's ridiculous and i
want you to know that you're on canned
camera and i want you to know that 4k
thank you
there is a real crisis of masculinity in
this in this culture that's one of the
um
not very widely discussed aspects of
the the lockdowns and everything in our
response to it
just a whole lot of cowardly
disgraceful embarrassing men like this
guy
um cowering yeah because that that's the
really sad thing is in these mask
shaming videos
so often and not in every case but so
many of these videos that we've played
on this show have been men
tearful
scared ridiculous men
um screaming at women for not having the
masks on
put a mask on you're scaring me
oftentimes it's men doing that
and of course he uses his grandparents
death
as a as a cudgel here as a weapon to
wield to shame this woman
yeah you can tell he's really upset
about his grand grandparents dying that
he's using it
as emotional blackmail
but really your um your your
grandparents died
because they got covered from someone at
a grocery store not wearing a mask is
that what you're saying
really
because that's that's not the way that
that most people got covered
in fact i'm not aware of any confirmed
case
of somebody getting coveted because
someone else because they walked they
walked by in a grocery store aisle they
walked by someone without a mask on
i'm not aware of one single confirmed
case of that
vast majority of people got kuga kovid
they got it from other people in their
home
from long
sustained
contact
with other people
you know in their families and around
them
the
the correct response
to something like that
or certainly a justified response to
something like that
is to grab the phone
and i don't blame the woman for not
doing this because you know she doesn't
know this guy is insane she doesn't know
how he'll react but i'm just saying a
more certainly a morally justified
response would be to grab that phone and
just chuck it all the way across the
store
that would absolutely be justified
if you're so afraid
then
just leave the store
if you're that afraid why are you
getting up in her face with your phone
and all of the the the older people that
he's talked about at the grocery store
um they're if they're if they're
concerned they're wearing masks
and if they really want a vaccination
they probably got one already
if they're that concerned
older americans were first in line for
um
for the vaccine is there any older
american
in america right now who really want the
vaccine and hasn't been able to get it
yet
there might be a few but i don't think
there's many
just uh a lot of cowardly a lot of
cowardly men who who should have been
the ones standing up against this
all of this madness but instead many of
them participating in it
all right uh
now we go to alexandria okay cortez
coming valiantly to the defense of mass
murderers
you know you might think that planned
parenthood kills over 300 000 babies a
year which it does
but aoc wants you to know that uh no
they don't kill babies they save babies
somehow
let's listen
first and foremost i don't want to hear
a single person on this committee or
outside of this committee talk about
what about uh valuing life when they
continue to uphold the death penalty
when they continue to support policies
that disproportionately incarcerate and
lead to the deaths of black men and
people throughout this country and
uphold in a in absolutely unjust medical
system that exists for profit that
allows people to die because they can't
afford to live in addition to that if we
want to talk about planned parenthood
let's talk about how many lives planned
parenthood has saved and how many babies
have been born because of the prenatal
care provided by planned parenthood and
if you don't if you don't believe it and
if you've never met a planned parenthood
baby i'm happy to let you know that i am
one and that my mother received and
relied on prenatal care from planned
parenthood when she was pregnant with me
and so if we're concerned about life
we don't get to talk about anyone else
who's not concerned about the full
spectrum of that when we are upholding
policies that kill people
why are you guys complaining about the
death camps i survived it
that's her argument
well i i was a planned parent planned
parenthood baby whatever that is
but my mother went into planned
parenthood uh when she was pregnant and
didn't have me dismembered in my skull
crush so what are you so concerned about
yeah she says let's talk about the
babies that planned parenthood has saved
okay
let's talk about it you brought the
subject go ahead
hump me a few bars what do you mean tell
me give me the statistics how many how
many in what way is planned parenthood
saving babies and how many have they
saved show me the statistics on that
because i don't even know what you mean
you babbling nincom poop
uh
and
if if they're saving babies let's just
for the sake of argument say that they
are that that is happening some which it
isn't happening at all by the way but
let's say for the sake of argument that
they've saved some babies uh are they
saving
more than 300 000 babies a year because
that's how many they're killing
and even if they were saving a million
babies a year does that make it okay
that they're killing three hundred
thousand
does that erase
you know what if
if if a serial killer
kills ten women and then uh and then
you know he's at a mcdonald's and
someone is choking and he performs the
heimlich maneuver and saves them does
that does that erase the people that he
just killed
as far as
planned parenthood providing prenatal
care to pregnant women
yeah um
some planned parenthood clinics will do
that
and the reason that they do it is it's a
way of
you know luring the pregnant women into
the building
but their primary business where they
make most of their money aside from the
the tax money that's sent to them half a
billion dollars a year but aside from
that where they're making most of their
money is for abortion
that's how they're keeping the doors
open
so yeah they they're going to lure
people in they lure the pregnant women
in with promises of prenatal care quote
unquote free birth control and all those
things
but what they're really interested in
doing is killing the babies
but one of the reasons why
planned parenthood
is able to provide so much quote-unquote
prenatal care
is because they're getting all the
funding from the government
and so they're able to set up shop
in all the cities and everywhere else
and their real purpose is to perform the
abortions because that's the money maker
but anyone there are many many many
thousands of women's clinics out there
pro-life women's clinics
um pregnancy care facilities
where they don't kill any babies
and they will provide all of the same
prenatal care and more
that planned parenthood provides but
they don't get the funding
okay no pro-life
pregnancy care center is getting half a
billion dollars a year in funding like
planned parenthood
so this is the little trick that you get
from democrats they say well we've got
to keep funding planned parenthood um
because they're you know they're in all
these cities and they're providing all
this care
they're in all these cities providing
all this care because you're funding
them
we could quite easily take that half a
billion away and give it to
facilities that don't kill babies
and there would be no loss of care
but
there's more more compassion there from
from the democrats and from aoc
compassionately defending
baby burgers
all right
uh there's here's a little bit of good
news a federal judge in washington on
wednesday declared that the u.s centers
for disease control prevention otherwise
known as the cdc um their moratorium
money on eviction a key element of the
federal government's efforts to aid
those hit hardest by the coveted
pandemic and its economic efforts
must be set aside so this is
the federal judge saying in other words
sifting through the media's
presentation of this of this uh of this
matter
the federal judge is saying that the cdc
doesn't have the authority
to tell landlords that they can't evict
their tenants
which is good that the judge is saying
that because of course they don't
obviously they don't
where does the cdc find where does it
derive its authority
to set policy for landlords across the
country
to come up with like housing policies
and telling landlords that they can't
evict their tenants who aren't paying
obviously they don't have that authority
that is nowhere in their purview
nowhere in their scope of authority uh
but they
they simply
took the authority
you know they didn't have to do much to
justify it or to explain why they should
have the ability or the power to do this
they just took
it like so many other government
agencies and so many other
petty tyrants at every level of
government
they didn't have the authority but they
took it
because there was a crisis and that's
what tyrants do in a crisis all right
number five so i i got to play this for
you i don't i don't have to play it but
but i will this one is uh
this is one you can't fully appreciate
without the video accompaniment
it's apparently a video made by a group
called the black hammer organization
that's what they call themselves
they're far left obviously
but they're they're i guess they're in a
beef with antifa specifically antifa of
colorado springs
and this is some kind of intra lefty
whack job dispute going on and they
recorded this video
with their leader in full joker makeup
and all the other people standing in the
back in masks like it's kind of like
like the
the um
the in a cartoon the main villain his
throwaway goons
so he so this guy's got those and
they're standing there in the back
and
this is what he said
hello antifa
it's me ghazi the commander-in-chief of
the black camera organization land back
i heard you had some not so nice things
to say about me
i heard you had so nice things to say
about my hammers
i heard you had
not so nice things
to do
to one of my members
one of my dear dear members
an african filipino mother that you
doxed and thought you could get away
with it thought we were gonna back down
thought we were gonna take it
no that's not gonna happen
you messed with the wrong one this time
yes oh yes you did
oh
yes you did cause we don't
take it lightly
when harm is done
to our african colonized women
that the cringe is so strong on that
oh man see this supports my theory
that antifa and its rival cousins are
they're really mostly theater kids who
didn't have any friends in high school
that's mostly what we're dealing with
and i actually mean that
almost sincerely they might not all be
theater kids but but for them
far left militancy is a cosplay it's a
game
it's a role play
you know there's there's a really strong
element of
insincerity
fraudulence
this kind of poser nerdy nerdishness
to all of this stuff
and
but they're also a real threat
not because any one of them individually
are at all intimidating
but when you take a whole mob of people
and uh and you let them do and they're
given free reign by by law enforcement
they're able to do whatever they want
and you equip them a lot of times
they're out there with guns and bats and
things yeah they're gonna be anyone
you could have a gang of actual toddlers
with
bats and guns and crowbars given free
reign to roam the city and they'd be a
threat
so individually yeah just a bunch of
absolute nerds
but they'd be given
full
run to do whatever they want especially
in places like portland
in fact there's another video that we i
can't even play because it's just it's
one customer after another you wouldn't
be able to hear anything but there's
another video out of portland
of um
antifa you know militants out in the
street with guns
stopping traffic
and a guy gets out of his car and he
pulls his own gun to defend himself
because he's got these whack jobs
putting guns at him and uh they mob him
and assault him
and take him down and and you know this
this is being filmed no police officer
in sight
they're able to do this
in portland and other places
they can go out into the street they can
they can pull out guns they can stop
traffic nobody stops them
but we should always keep in mind
that although they're a threat they are
a danger for the reasons i've given
these are domestic terrorists
and they should be treated as such
but we should always remember that the
fraudulence the the inherent fraudulence
to this and uh and
the fact that the the anger and the rage
that they supposedly feel about whatever
injustice they think they're protesting
against it's not real
this is all a game
as we can clearly see there
i think it's probably true to say that
most people who have credit cards have a
higher balance on those credit cards
than they would prefer and certainly are
paying a higher interest than they'd
prefer and the higher interest than they
need to pay that's why you gotta you
gotta look into light stream if you're
looking for a way to save some extra
money why not start by paying less
interest on your credit card balances
because that's just money you're burning
on those interest rates refinance with a
credit card consolidation loan from
lightstream it's an easy way to save
hundreds
uh to even thousands of dollars and
lower your interest rates at the same
time lightstream offers credit card
consolidation loans from 5.95 apr with
auto pay and excellent credit you can
lower the average credit card interest
rate of over 18 percent apr plus there
are no fees on top of it you can get
even get your money as soon as the day
you apply so this is stop burning money
start saving money and just for my
listeners apply now to get a special
interest rate rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is to go to lightstream.com
walsh that's l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com walsh
subject to credit approval rates range
from 5.95 apr to 19.99 percent apr and
include 0.5 auto pay discount lowest
rate requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit
lightstream.com walsh for more
information
all right moving on now to reading the
youtube comments
this one says that to be fair matt a
socially distanced wedding reception
without dancing sounds right up your
alley well yeah it is right up my alley
absolutely
but not like this not for this reason
that's what i've been saying all along
the dancing band
at weddings in in in dc
the idea of a wedding without dancing
sounds great to me but not for the
reason
that the mayor or the empress of dc is
giving
and her reason is that somehow dancing
causes covet
amber martin says matt you're totally
throwing me off with the new profile
picture on twitter new podcast cover and
new theme tune too much change at once i
can't handle it like i understand i'm
not a big fan of change either
uh and we did we did throw a lot of you
guys all at once
but you know what it's for your own good
in the long run
um
let's see
deplorable neanderthal says my goodness
that new intro made me think i was in
the wrong place for a moment but then i
realized the host's comments were
sufficiently bigoted and i knew i wasn't
well there we go you know you you you
hear the hatred and bigotry and you know
you've come to the right place
uh scott says matt i'm watching this
while in the sauna you really have
viewers from all around the world
well you're obviously banned for the
show from the show for that because i i
do not unders i think i sat in a sauna
one time in my life i don't understand
it
and my one time in a sauna there was
nobody else there and i was there for
like two minutes
and what you you sit there and it's
really hot and uncomfortable and that's
it you sit there
and then you add other people into the
sauna with you
who are sitting there sometimes half
naked or or more naked than that
and you're all uncomfortable and
sweating and hot and you're sitting
there next to each other
staring aimlessly what what is the
attraction what is the appeal
ban from the show
and
ebell says matt i agree there's a lot of
mental disorders that are bs but odd
oppositional defiance disorder is
different basically the kid will do
everything in their power to do things
their way what makes it such an issue is
isn't just the defiance but the
aggression that can come with it the
reason i believe this is a necessary
diagnosis is because my approach with
those clients is different when i
provide them with instruction
my goal isn't isn't whether or not they
can complete my task it's will they do
it without destruction or aggression
toward others
you make valid arguments for there not
being clear boundaries for certain
criterion of diagnosis but maladaptive
behavior such as aggression and property
destruction should be met with behavior
therapy
i'm not advocating for medicating it
though but if we don't have a diagnosis
insurance companies are going to pay
aren't going to help help pay for these
extreme behaviors well
okay
first of all
describing a kid who wants to do things
their own way again
that does sound just like a normal kid
to me
but if you want to say that there are
some kids
that are far beyond the average as far
as that goes
and a lot more oppositional and defiant
and destructive than other kids
fine i agree
and if you want to say
that kids who are behaving like that
who you can't get them to listen at all
and they're very destructive and they're
they're they're way too aggressive and
violent if you want to say that okay we
need to we need to work with them
quote-unquote behavior therapy trying to
correct those behaviors fine that's
totally fine
all i'm saying
is we shouldn't call it a mental illness
you know these kids aren't sick
and they certainly don't have an illness
in the sense that somebody with cancer
or diabetes has an illness
that's my point
yeah there are some behaviors that a
person can
exhibit especially kids
that are
bad
that you want to correct
that make it difficult for them to
function in home or in a school setting
i'm not saying we shouldn't try to
correct those behaviors
i'm only saying that we shouldn't call
it an illness
it is simply a behavior that needs to be
corrected
often times you can do that in the home
you know in in some cases yeah it may
require therapy perfectly fine
but it's not an illness and it sounds
like you
would almost agree with that because
you're saying you wouldn't medicate it
when you move on to medication that's
when you're treating it like it's an
illness or sickness you know
along the lines of cancer or diabetes or
something which it isn't
that's my point
you know we have a lot of great sponsors
on this show that we're happy and proud
to be able to bring to you but we want
to know you know we want to know more
when we're setting up the show and when
we have sponsors we want to know we want
to do that with you in mind and we want
to know what kind of products and
services are going to be best for you
and that's why we've got this survey
we've been telling you about all week
you can go to dailywire.com walsh and
fill out my audience survey to tell us a
little bit more about yourself and that
way we're going to find the sponsors and
service and products that are that you
really want to hear about and tailor it
more to you
to sweeten the whole experience those of
you that complete the survey will be
entered to win a 1 000 gift card you can
only take the survey once per show which
means you do it once on my show you get
entered for a thousand dollar gift card
but you can also go listen to ben
shapiro michael knowles and andrew
clavin get access to their surveys and
uh and have a even more of a chance to
win that cert win that card so again my
survey link is dailywire.com
walsh
also starting tomorrow saturday may 8th
you can get the first episode of ben
shapiro's new series debunked on his
podcast feed and also a new episode
every saturday for the first season if
you're not familiar he addresses common
leftist talking points and dismantles
them in about 15 minutes or less so you
should probably check it out and it's a
great show very well done and put
together daily wire members can get the
full 10 episode first season over at
dailywire.com if you're not already a
member get 20 off today with code
debunked while the discount lasts first
up he debunks the fallacy of a living
minimum wage
uh and many other fallacies after that
so check it out tomorrow on the bench
shapiro podcast feed over at apple
spotify or wherever uh whatever your
platform of choice happens to be now
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to florida where in the story we're
about to discuss there are cancellations
to be handed out to everyone it's once
again a friday cancel fest which is my
favorite kind of friday let's read now
from the new york post report it says a
florida teen who allegedly schemed with
her mom to rig an election for
homecoming queen is being charged as an
adult
emily rose grover was 17 when she and
her mother were arrested for hacking
student accounts and casting nearly 250
bogus votes so she could snag the
homecoming crown but grover turned 18
last month in the state attorney office
in escambia county confirmed tuesday
that she'll be tried as an adult grover
and her mother 50 year old laura rose
carroll are facing multiple felonies for
fixing the october homecoming vote at
tate high school in pensacola carroll is
an assistant principal at bellevue
elementary school in the same county
okay now
take a
pause here for a minute you might be
thinking that the words charged as an
adult and rigged a homecoming queen
election
should not appear in the same sentence
together
this would seem to be an enormously out
of proportion penalty given the nature
of the offense
but maybe the rest of the story will
change your mind or maybe it won't
continuing
an investigation into the vote was
sparked a month after the election when
escambia county school district
officials reported unauthorized access
to student accounts
investigators said they found 117 votes
originated from the same ip address over
a short period of time a total of 246
votes were cast from accounts that were
accessed by computers inside the mom and
daughters pensacola home or from carol's
cell phone
some students said grover had boasted
about using her mother's school district
account to cast the votes investigators
learned that since august 2019 carol's
account accessed 372 high school records
and 339 of those were tate students
charges against the mom and daughter
included unlawful use of a two-way
communications device and criminal use
of personally identifiable information
each faces a maximum of 16 years on the
charges and grover was expelled from her
high school according to the ap
all right so no actually the rest of the
story really doesn't change the initial
judgment that this is a wildly overboard
response
yes they access student accounts to rig
the homecoming election
uh that's bad
but it's a homecoming election
now if the if the article had said that
they had murdered her potential
challengers to the throne and buried
them in the woods in order to win
homecoming queen i'd agree that felony
charges and many years in prison would
be in order but for this
why is the court system concerned
concerning itself with this at all
is life in escambia county so sunny and
perfect and conflict-free that they have
time to use the criminal courts to
litigate a homecoming election
controversy
i would have thought that this offense
would warrant maybe a few days of
after-school detention or suspension at
most but arrest expulsion and 16 years
in prison
this is like deer hunting with an m60
the the term overkill doesn't even begin
to cover it
but
that's not even what makes this case
especially outrageous
for that we have to harken back to
another story from a few weeks ago
you might recall this uh reading now
from the post-millennial says the two
teen girls who were charged with murder
after allegedly attempting to hijack the
car of a pakistani immigrant working for
a food delivery app
have reached a plea deal with
prosecutors according to the daily mail
the mail reports that the plea deal
ensures that they will not be held past
the age of 21 nor be placed in a prison
facility
disturbing video of the incident shows
muhammad anwar 66 being killed after the
girls allegedly sped off with his car as
he attempted to hold on to his vehicle
while drove off the car then crashed and
flipped on its side killing on war the
suspects are a 13 year old from
southeast dc and a 15 year old from fort
worth washington
the juveniles names were not released so
two teen girls who carjacked a guy
killed him in the process and left him
for dead on the sidewalk while they
frantically tried to save their phones
from the wreck
were not charged as adults and faced no
prison time at all but a teen girl who
rigged a homecoming election
will be charged as an adult
and faces a decade and a half behind
bars
does that
make any sense what exactly is the
message we're getting from the justice
system here
that it's kind of bad to kill a guy for
his car but to fraudulently claim the
title of homecoming queen is an atrocity
on a whole new level
that theft and murder are mere youthful
indiscretions but sending in fake votes
for homecoming queen isn't
that two girls who killed a man and
cared more for their lost phones than
his lost life
present no threat to the community
but the silly girl who cheated the
system so she could wear a tierra and a
sash for a night has to be locked in a
cage in order to protect the
innocent perhaps that that's the message
or the message is that justice has
become a mostly random and arbitrary
thing in this country
and it's very often determined by the
ideological bent of the person dulling
it out
now it's fair to point out that these
are two different jurisdictions right
florida and dc
perhaps down in florida where they give
the homecoming queen 16 years
maybe they'd give the carjacking
murderers 16 decades that's certainly
possible but it still does provide a
stark contrast
and also
can't help but note
just one more piece of evidence that
white privilege is an imaginary
construction of the left it's not a
reality because
the girl getting the book thrown at her
is white
the girls who got a slap on the wrist
for killing another human being are
black
now even if they're different
jurisdictions
this is certainly not the sort of
dichotomy you would envision in a
country with white privilege
you know if someone if someone on the
left if you didn't know anything about
this country and and someone on the left
told you about white privilege
and then you saw these two stories you'd
be really really confused
in fact you'd probably envision
something like
the exact reverse of this situation
so what does that tell you
well it tells you for one thing
that the white privilege myth
is canceled and so is florida
and so is this girl's mom because
obviously she's the one who should get
almost all the blame for this crime in
the first place i can say that when i
was 17 if my parents came to me and
suggested suggested that i cheat
on anything and offered to help me do it
my response at that age would have been
really hell yeah let's go
what 17 year old wouldn't have that
reaction to their own parents suggesting
that they cheat
so the mom is canceled along with the
whole state
and dc is canceled also and uh everyone
else remotely connected to either of
these stories
is cancelled
just how i like to end it on a friday
and we'll leave it there hope you have a
great weekend talk to you next week
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matt
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin